the Democrats have found us out just as
we American Catholics were on the cusp
of rising up dissolving the government
instituting theocracy loyal to Rome
instituting mandatory dress codes of
albs Kasich's zucchet ii and miters just
as the opus dei we're finally going to
replace the US Constitution with the
Catechism of the Catholic Church the
Democrats found us out we would have
gotten away with it too if it weren't
for you meddling Democrats we will
analyze the sudden return of
anti-catholic bigotry to American public
discourse through attacks on the
Federalist Society from CNN to the floor
of the US Senate then speaking of CNN
the cable news network airs a segment on
illegal aliens that seems to lose a
little bit in translation this clip is
too good to miss and nobody is talking
about it
wonder why finally speaking of the
Federalists we will analyze the last
time demagogues attacked a Federalists
this severely as Aaron Burr kills
Alexander Hamilton on this day in
history
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
it's time to join the conversation again
on Tuesday July 17th at 5:30 Eastern
2:30 Pacific and replevin answers your
questions moderated by the beautiful and
dauntless Alicia Kraus the Q&A will
stream live on YouTube and Facebook for
everyone to watch but only subscribers
can ask drew questions over at daily
wire.com
check out the pinned comments on this
video for more information
once again subscribe to get your
questions answered by andrew Clavin the
Supreme Lord of the multiverse Tuesday
July 17th 5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 Pacific
and join the conversation we've got a
shocking clip to play for you where we
get started from the ben shapiro show it
really is gonna knock your socks off
before we get to that though I've got to
make a little money honey and we got to
think peter moeller i know what you're
thinking you're saying michael gosh look
at that shirt mmm you look so wow yeah I
know
I know that's why it's because I'm
wearing Peter Millar Peter Millar my
favorite clothing company if Peter
Millar is actually solves a real problem
which is they have this very high
quality excellent menswear clothes a lot
of clothing you know not just golf wear
anymore but they've got polo shirts and
pants and shorts and it just looks
really really good clothing for
everybody but it also solves a problem
for me a sag of own of Sicilian descent
which is that you don't really it
doesn't sweat through very easily it's
really good quality I was founded in
2001 with a single cashmere sweater and
it's grown into a premium American
lifestyle brand featuring a whole range
of casual sportswear tailored menswear
and luxury performance golf apparel it's
comfort fit quality style all setting
the standard in menswear so right now
I'm wearing the performance polo but
I've got a ton of their clothing and I'm
getting more of it it's I'm not joking
it's actually my favorite clothing
company in in the country it is like so
because the fit is all really nice and
it's just you know it allows less a man
to move around it's like got a little
stretch to it and also it you know you
don't like sweat through it instantly as
I do through every other piece of
clothing what I love about Peter Millar
polo shirts is they offer a comfort end
style so you know it's perfect for
golfing and it's but it's also perfect
for going to the office even you know
even this place
I mean most people are walking around
here wearing like tank tops and like
cut-offs and all you know the potato
sacks but this is you know really ups
the quality of the place the performance
polo I'm wearing is the most comfortable
shirt I've ever worn I can say that
about the performance shorts I can say
that about the pants everything else
I've worn from there right now head over
to Peter Millar comm / co f f/a co v fe
f e check out some of my Peter Millar
favorites be sure to use my link you
will receive complimentary shipping and
a free hat that's very important summer
is on the way you can get a sunburn on
your scalp we're ahead get a free hat
today don't say I never did nothing for
you Peter Millar mi ll AR comm slash
golf FA CE o VF e Fe Peter Miller gum /
Co FFA we have got to get to the
anti-catholic bigotry that has just
bubbled up in the last two weeks before
that though before we get to Catholicism
I have to talk about an Orthodox Jew Ben
Shapiro said something really shocking
on his show today it was broadly about
Yale Law School just play the clip and
we can talk about it so Yale Law School
is let's face it a second-rate law
school I mean I went to Harvard so I
should know and the Yale Law Students
are proving themselves to be inferior
law students just as Yale proved itself
an inferior College by accepting my
friend Michael Knowles into its school
the reality is yale law students seem
not to know exactly how judicial
appointments work i know it's absolutely
shocking to say that sort of thing
publicly on air he called me his friend
can you believe this my jaw dropped when
I saw that clip incredible it is you
know the story that Ben is referencing
is that these Yale Law students these
very recent yale law students the last
few years are very upset that a Yale Law
graduate Brett Kavanaugh is now going to
be on the Supreme Court and they're very
upset that Yale Law issued a press
release and said hey we're proud that
one of our graduates has been nominated
to the Supreme Court that's pretty good
and they said how dare you it's people
are gonna die Rober and it is really sad
because a number of the people on that
list were contemporaries and classmates
of mine in undergraduate so I do know a
bunch of them and they're pretty they
were eccentric they were not
at parties you know that kind of like my
I don't know nothing's fun everything's
terrible I mean really far left radical
left people so you know
okay guys you signed your name to the
petition I bet that'll stop Cavanaugh I
bet that'll stop him from going to the
court very funny and and Ben called me a
friend okay so let's move on to the main
story which is the anti-catholic bigotry
and it really is bubbling up like crazy
here this is not a new experience in the
United States
CNN ran this piece today the question is
why do Catholics hold a strong majority
on the Supreme Court simple enough
question there are a lot of Catholics on
the Supreme Court
Byron Wolfe wrote this piece in the
crystal is a section of CNN the point he
says quote there's only ever been one
Catholic president and Catholics or a
declining portion of the u.s. population
but they're holding a strong majority in
the US Supreme Court when President
Donald Trump nominated Brett Kavanaugh
of the Supreme Court Tuesday night
Cavanaugh described his Catholic faith
and the importance of the church in his
life from the high school he attended to
the Catholic Youth Organization
basketball teams he now coaches ooh
Catholic Youth Organization basketball
ooh right you're getting very nervous as
you read this if confirmed Cavanaugh
will replace Anthony Kennedy who is
Catholic ish Trump's other nominee now
justice Neal Gorsuch replaced Catholic
Antonin Scalia Gorsuch attends Episcopal
churches now but was raised Catholic
CNN's Daniel Burke has written that that
about Gorsuch his faith which he keeps
private and it is a complicated matter
so all right oh he's got faith he might
believe in God oh this is complicated
this is scary aren't you afraid every
other Republican appointed justice he
writes on the court is Catholic and
Democrat appointed Sonia Sotomayor was
raised Catholic
during her nomination she described
herself as a cultural Catholic so let's
just take that part for a second it's
all this insinuation and this is what
the left has been adding to the
conversation for weeks now I'm not being
anti Catholic but isn't it strange isn't
it strange all of these Catholics show
up on the court he go he actually goes
on in this piece a justices religion
does not nor should it matter
but it is certainly a curiosity of
modern politics that Catholic and Jewish
justices have found such success yeah
it's a very curiosity on the courts that
said have so many Catholic and Jewish
justices yeah yeah I was doing that was
did my Martin Luther impression by the
way I don't know what you thought that
was but there is a perception he goes on
that male Catholics on the court are
more likely to vote against abortion and
perhaps plays a role among conservatives
looking to chip away at roe v wade just
that language there is a perception that
says it all this is the mainstream media
trick it was a critics say that George W
Bush is a terrible mean monster critics
say some people say and that's the
reason there is a perception there's a
perception among whom what perception
what do you mean there's a perception no
you think that you are insinuating that
there is an insinuation by CNN that
Catholics are going to throw away the
Constitution and judge cases based on
what the Pope tells them to do that's
what CNN is saying that's what there is
there is a perception that's there is a
perception and of course justices
religion should not matter and how they
read the Constitution but very often the
the fastest-growing religion in the
country atheism does affect how people
view it there the final piece of this he
says Anna Pew survey from 2014 the
fastest growing religious group is
unaffiliated which grew from sixteen
point one percent in 2007 to twenty two
point eight percent eclipsing
Catholicism in the u.s. in the process
so he's saying he's saying on the one
hand these kind of ask personal aspects
of our character they shouldn't affect
how we interpret the text we should
interpret the text as it's written on
the other hand the Supreme Court should
reflect the population broadly but the
Supreme Court's not a popular
institution the Supreme Court isn't the
legislature it's not supposed to
represent the people you're supposed to
interpret the law it's the the logos the
logic of the country not the pathos not
the spirit of the emotion of the country
and so he wants to have asked a
community to and it's all just
insinuation this is nothing new
anti-catholic bigotry in the United
States has always been this way or if
they're Schlessinger the the 20th
century historian he said that
anti-catholicism
he's a quote the deepest bias in his
three of the American people we don't
think of it that way popularly we think
the biases racism or sexism or anti
American Indian or whatever
anti-catholicism from the very beginning
has been a defining feature of the
United States but it's kind of taken
different forms and now it is bubbling
up on the Left a Thomas Nast the great
political cartoonist he drew a cartoon
in the nineteenth century of Catholics
little bishops as crocodile's on the
American Ganges it was Catholic
crocodiles climbing up the river Ganges
to subvert the United States but we
actually got public schools in America
because of anti-catholicism that's where
a lot of our public education comes from
because there was a senator from Maine I
believe James Blaine who was so worried
about the proliferation of Catholic
schools in the United States you know
for all of Western history just about
the Catholic schools have played a role
in educating the the elite and have
educated so many people in the last two
millenium so he was worried about the
proliferation of them in the US and he
said that we need public schooling that
is non-sectarian u.s. grant same thing
was afraid of Catholic schooling so he
came out and he said he feared a future
where patriotism and intelligence was on
one side and superstition ambition and
greed was on the other all of that
referring to Catholics he said he wanted
schools unmixed with quote atheistic
pagan or sectarian teaching the u.s.
grant this a you know good general good
president and sectarian was the
euphemism used for Catholic so you see
this even on the Republican side
bubbling up for a while before we get to
where it's going now on the Left it's
got to make a little money honey make a
little money with honey honey is a
product that I've been using forever
I've been using them for years and years
long before the daily wire ever existed
and it's coming it's coming it's upon us
you know this I know this anybody who's
married to his kids was parents who has
selfish desires to buy urine products at
the biggest shopping day in the universe
is coming Amazon Prime day this is an
epic day of the year there were gigantic
savings across the biggest marketplace
in the universe did you know that there
is such a thing as prime day every day
this is true there
oh you can install this little add-on to
the browser honey and it will
automatically find you the best deals
while you're shopping you don't have to
go searching for coupon codes you don't
need to check multiple websites it just
will do it for you with honey honey is
the free browser extension that helps
you get the absolute best deals possible
on sites like Amazon so I go on Amazon I
buy a lot of books for instance you know
I'm always on Amazon and it will say oh
you can get better price here you can
get it here this will go down it just
went up and it just applies everything
for you if there's a better price honey
will find it in seconds you might
remember in the bad old days when you'd
go buy something online you'd search and
type in the coupon code and then it
wouldn't work and it's a like only 50%
of these have worked today you think
well then I don't think I'm gonna be in
the winning 50% of that oh you got to
look good for doing it takes look save
your time and money honey will
automatically find you the best deal it
is free there is no reason not to
install it do it right now it's it's
that good I couldn't tell you the last
purchase I made with honey because I
make all of my purchases with honey I
use it constantly it's I mean it is I
don't even know how much money it saved
me over the years but I'm certain it's
thousands of dollars because I've been
using it at least I don't know five six
years at this point
it's free it takes two clicks to install
consider yourself prepared for the best
Amazon Prime day ever with honey start
saving today prime day and every day get
honey for free at join honey calm slash
cough fa ce o-- v fa e fa e join honey
calm slash cough fa that's where we get
you can thank aunty catholicism for
public schools you know there's that
great institution in America public
schooling because there was a fear of
Catholics this used to be a big issue
among the Republicans you actually had
this this Reverend Samuel Bouchard who
is a Republican he had this quote he
said we are Republicans and don't
propose to leave our party and identify
ourselves with the party whose
antecedents have been rum Romanism and
rebellion and I only like two of those
three by the way I only like two of
those three rum rum anism and rebellion
now this it wasn't only Republicans
there what the KKK was anti-catholic
that was the terrorist wing of the
Democrat Party and now the Democrats are
the anti-catholic ones but they've been
the
subject of a lot of a lot of bigotry in
the u.s. in 1891 the largest mass
lynching in American history was against
Sicilians was against Catholic Sicilians
in 1921 father James Coyle
was assassinated in Birmingham by a
Methodist minister talking about fire
and brimstone minister goes that there
actually kills a Catholic priest and
where this really came to a head the
last time we had a real bubbling of
aunty Catholicism in America was JFK and
JFK being just a crass degenerate
Democrat politician it took exactly the
wrong approach on this the question when
JFK was running for president 1960 was
if you have a Catholic in the White
House is he just gonna take his orders
from the Pope what if the Pope tells him
to do something is he gonna do that does
the Pope then control the United States
and we laugh at that now but this was
the anti-catholic fear then the way JFK
approached this really has poisoned
religion in American politics in many
ways since here's JFK I believe in an
America where the separation of church
and state is absolute
I believe in a president whose views on
religion are its own private a fail
neither imposed upon him by the nation
nor imposed by the nation upon him as
they condition to holding that office so
what he says is look I'm I'm a Catholic
running for president the way that I'm
going to catholic catholicism is going
to inform my presidency is not at all
whatsoever i'm don't even really think
about it that much seriously I'm not
that Catholic that's his response but
that's crazy of course our views our
religious views inform our views of
other things in the world politics is
downstream of culture culture comes from
the cult it comes from what we worship
so this shouldn't affect how we view the
Constitution we shouldn't want to
rewrite the Constitution into the
catechism of the Catholic Church but of
course it affects our views on the world
we view the world in a certain way
through this lens we think that human
life has dignity and purpose because of
our religious views some religions don't
believe that some people think human
life doesn't have any dignity that we
can kill it and it doesn't matter at all
that life doesn't have a purpose is just
about giving ourselves pleasure all the
time that we don't really have any sort
of free will
we're just a bunch of bumbling sacks of
cells and neurons walking around like
zombies pretending that were individual
people your religion informs how you
think about everything there's this
ridiculous canard they say well you
can't legislate morality all legislation
legislates morality what what do you
think Obamacare does what do you think
forcing certain people off their health
care plans and taking money from them to
pay for other people's health care plans
if they don't what do you think that
does that's let of course that's
legislating a moral point what do you
think low taxes or what do you think
raising taxes is that's a moral point
they say we need to take from the 1% and
give it to the 99% that's a moral
statement what do you think foreign
policy is you're making moral claims
about which people were going to protect
which people were not going to protect
what interests we're going to fight for
though these are all moral questions to
all politics is the affairs of men and
men or moral agents so you know when we
interact with each other those are moral
transactions of course legislation has a
moral component it's just a lie from
people who take a very shallow view of
religion and that shallow view of
religion is where this anti Catholicism
is coming from because by the way it's
not just anti-catholicism we're seeing
that with the Supreme Court nominees
it's really anti Christianity it's
really anti Western religion and so
you've seen it in the media a lot
recently for priests showed up to a
Donald Trump rally great moves great
work Padres really like it sometimes
there are a couple streams in public
Catholic life there's the one that like
believes in Catholicism and then there's
the one that's like a little more hippy
dippy and it gets a little little more
heterodox in their views so good job
Padres I really liked like he's sticking
up there but when Amy Barrett was being
considered for this seat on the Supreme
Court there were major news stories that
said she was in a cult is that the
Catholic Church is a cult now right or
she was you know she was in this little
religious group that killed each other
accountable and you know read the Bible
and stuff he said that's a cult because
they have a shallow view of religion
daily beast writer Michael Jay
Michaelson said that Donald Trump is
quote carrying out the agenda of a small
secretive network of extremely
conservative Catholic activists the
secret agenda the Opus Dei
is coming and he's referring to leonard
leo the head of the federalist society
and the guy he doesn't first of all
what's so incredible is that The Daily
Beast writer doesn't know he doesn't
know anything about Catholicism he said
this guy Leonard Lee he's so crazy
he goes to Mass every day and he
actually he didn't even say he just goes
to Mass he says he says Mass which isn't
true priests say Mass so he just doesn't
even even the very basic thing of what
the masses this guy has no idea
whatsoever is in that crazy goes to myth
she's probably prays to hey I heard he
even reads his Bible right now I mean
that he goes on to be sure none of this
is to repeat the odious claims of
anti-catholicism of papist conspiracies
and dual loyalty of course though you
know when you say it's like when you
follow a sentence with but when you say
but it negates the sentence that's
reason is I don't want to do negate I
don't want to repeat any of that
anti-catholic papist conspiracy stuff
but he goes to mass boom be afraid you
know CNN's Dean Obeidallah said that
there are these this cabal of people
trying to push Christian Sharia law and
obviously when it comes to the Supreme
Court
this is anti-catholicism they're talking
about and of course there is the irony
right because they're saying that
Christianity is so terrible because it's
like Islam and meanwhile they're telling
us how great Islam is where all of this
comes from is an interview that Antonin
Scalia gave to the New York Magazine a
number of years ago this actually
highlights all of it very well and what
it highlights is that people are
biblically illiterate in this country
and because you have a whole a whole
generation out which has been raised
without religion they it's just utterly
other to them they can't engage in
religious questions they don't
understand how religion works because
they've been raised by postmodern
superstition rather than a traditional
religion in this interview I'll just
read you a fair little chunk of this
interview this girl at the New York
Magazine she she asks him about his
views on religion do you believe in Hell
oh yeah I believe in Hell and he is so
Scalia's very charming and funny and
he's so surprised that she is asking
these questions he leans in with a stage
whisperin says you know
even believe in the devil and the New
York magazine lady goes isn't it
terribly frightening to believe in the
devil and he this is the line the take
away you're looking at me as though I'm
weird my god are you so out of touch
with most of America most of which
believes in the devil I mean Jesus
Christ believed in the devil it's in the
Gospels you travel in circles that are
so so removed from mainstream America
that you were appalled that anybody
would believe in the devil
most of mankind has believed in the
devil for all of history many more
intelligent people than you or me have
believed in the devil and that line when
I read that that really stuck with me
many more intelligent people than you or
me have believed in the devil at the
time I wasn't even I probably wouldn't
have called myself Christian I wouldn't
have really thought of myself in a
religious sense but that really stuck
with me because obviously that's true
and and this really gets to the heart of
what this new anti Catholicism is it's
it's a defense of modernity the reason
that this anti Catholicism is bubbling
up is because antiochus Catholicism
opposes modernity you know theoretically
all of our churches should be opposing
modernity but we've seen these stories
in recent weeks where churches are
getting getting a little weak-kneed
aren't they the Episcopalian Church
which has been crumbling for a long time
now they're they have women priests they
you know fly gay pride flags outside of
the church now the Episcopalian Church
in the u.s. that wants to give God a
different gender so they're gonna God's
gender-neutral now they're trying to
neuter God
good luck buddy if you read the Old
Testament it doesn't go very well when
that happens but so that's fallen away a
lot of sort of mainstream evangelical
protestant churches in America have
become left-wing have become a little
social justice II have become a little
soft have become very modern and in
support this makes sense because paratus
the Protestant revolution is what began
the modern era and that followed a
certain logical course the Catholic
Church ate modern it is now even though
there we have some acoustic guitar
churches here it is pretty rock solid
and you know it's defending 2000 year
old dogma that is why the left
absolutely despises at the left
is a jealous God leftism is a jealous
God when when Dianne Feinstein looked at
Amy Coney Barrow and she's being
nominated for the federal court and she
said I'm very afraid of this because the
dogma lives loudly within you all of the
religious conservatives thought that's
up crazy that's a religious test you
can't do that
well you know blah blah blah what Dianne
Feinstein's fear was wasn't that the
Catholic dogma lives loudly within Amy
Barrett it's that leftist modern Dogma
therefore does not live within Amy
Barrett because if you if you were a
flick news you're rejecting in no small
part modern views that the views that
came up in a counter been in response to
the Catholic Church in opposition to the
Catholic Church and they don't like that
so you're allowed to be a JFK Catholic
you're allowed to say oh um I go to
church I like the smells in the bells
you know I like the kind of silly hats
and the clothing and everything but I
would never reject modern orthodoxies I
would never reject I don't know the
redefinition of marriage or abortion or
I would never reject those things are
one of those are those are the modern
sacraments but the minute that you come
out you say no I actually believe in the
dogma then they hit you and it's gonna
come back I mean right now we're seeing
a huge backlash to modernism we're
seeing it fall apart in many ways
because of its illogical ends because of
the craziness of choosing your own
gender just a few years ago I'm old
enough to remember there were only two
genders now there are 56 and they're
multiplying a few years ago it was
lesbian gay and bisexual
now it's LGBTQ PA and LMNOP WXYZ and it
goes on and on and on and it gets crazy
there is a reaction that's going on to
this and and you're gonna see a lot of
the same themes of anti-catholicism that
are coming back you know a Hilaire
Belloc they create a French English
Catholic writer he said that to reject
the faith the Catholic faith is to write
yourself down forever as suburban peace
that's very elitist sort of snobbish
statement but there is something to it
the analogy could be in political
conservatism as well there is this kind
of rock-ribbed bedrock
that hasn't been brought off onto the
the rails and modernity too much and
that's what the left is reacting to and
that's what some people on the right are
reacting true as well unfortunately
people like Tommy Lara and I've been
very mean to Tommy Lauren recently and
I'm gonna have to be a little bit mean
in my last few minutes of this segment
today without further ado I feel so bad
hitting on Tommy
well I wouldn't feel bad hitting on
Tommy you know when I was single but I
feel bad
attacking Tommy because she's on the
right I think to hit rightward is
basically grave mortal sin but sometimes
you got to do it here is Tommy Lauren
doubling down on her pro-abortion
fanaticism on Fox News I think that it's
important to clarify it my statements
there because first and foremost I
believe that Judge Cavanaugh is a
constitutional conservative not a
religious judicial activist which is
exactly what we want my problem is with
some of my fellow conservatives who have
put it out there that we are quote
coming for roe v wade that is a mistake
because we are putting it out there and
implying that we are sending a justice a
justice to the bench to carry out
religious judicial activism which is a
mistake and is unconstitutional and if
we as conservatives are going to imply
that if that's going to be our messaging
we might as well spit on the
Constitution that is not what we stand
for if we are not going to uphold the
Constitution on its merit who will that
is up to us to do so that my real
problem here regardless of my views on
abortion pro-life pro-choice is the
messaging of our Supreme Court justice
and how he will handle roe v wade if it
comes to that point she just doesn't
know anything she just doesn't know if
she is saying words which we recognize
so we are mistaking that for an opinion
but that isn't as just words mashed
together conveying nothing to take her
main point I'm gonna you know I actually
invited Tommy on the show to see if she
wanted it so that I could correct some
things but she she responded with
something of a firm no so I don't know
maybe if people don't Witter want to try
to get her to come on the show that
might be nice because really what she's
saying now can't go without a response
it's so
wrong and stupid that it needs to be
responded to because she's got these
millions and millions of viewers on Fox
News where she's regularly spouting this
nonsense so it does demand a response I
fear well she's spouting things like
this
I fear that she's going to end up just
becoming one of these ex Republican
lefties like or on every other news
channel you know the Steve Schmidt types
and Anna Navarro's and David Fromm and
whatever you know they go on and they
bash the Republican Party I fear that
because what she's saying doesn't make
any sense the religious judicial
activism what is the judicial activism
the question is on Roe vs. Wade and
cases that immediately preceded it in
cases that followed from it Oh duh is
roe v wade decided constitutionally is
there a constitutional right to an
abortion is there more broadly a
constitutional right a general right to
privacy what do you think Tommy Lauren
is there no the answer is no and most
lefties will even admit that to you so
if the Constitution does not enshrine a
right to abortion if the framers in
Philadelphia didn't think that they were
saying okay and thank goodness we fought
that bloody Revolutionary War against
the Brits so we can finally kill our
babies hooray hip hooray General
Washington if that wasn't what the
framers were thinking which I don't
think they were then that case was
unconstitutionally decided if we want to
overturn an obviously
anti-constitutional case that's not
judicial activism that's returning the
judiciary to interpreting the law as it
says to interpreting the words of the
law by what they mean that's the
opposite of judicial activism I suppose
you could call it activist in the sense
that you're you're actively undoing
something that was act activists achill
II done there reminds me of the
chesterton quote there's a thought that
stops thought that's the thought that
ought to be stopped
oh she uses the phrase religious though
she attaches that here you she thinks
there's no non-religious reason to
overturn roe v-- wade you regardless of
anyone's religious views we should
overturn roe v wade it's not
constitutional
it's anti-constitutional it rips apart
it spits on the constitution and then
she's hung up on this religious thing
says when people because some people do
have
just motivations for overturning roe v
wade a million babies die a year in the
united states and that number is down i
mean that's a that's a relatively lower
number million babies die a year in the
united states because of that decision
so there are religious motivations
people who don't like worship Moloch or
something or Baal you know want want to
see that stop
but overturning roe v-- wade first of
all wouldn't be a lies abortion
everywhere they'd be a lot of states
that still preserve abortion laws it's a
it's a constitutional question and just
because there are religious motivations
that doesn't negate the merits of the
argument plenty of good
overturning of cases have been motivated
for religious reasons
how about Dred Scott the Dred Scott
decision was motivated for religious
reasons wasn't it Dred Scott which said
the black people can't be citizens in
the United States they're not entitled
to rights even free blacks that that
decision in 1857 was that I was
motivated by almost exclusively
Christian abolitionists to have returned
that is that does that negate it they
say oh you have religious motivation so
no okay black people should still be
barred from citizenship in any
protections in the United States how
about buck V Bell buck V Bell is a
lesser known among the general
population Supreme Court case from 1927
that allowed for the forcible
sterilization of the mentally unfit and
of criminals is that and there was one
dissent there was a lone dissent on that
it was the Catholic judge in that case
there was the lone dissent it was
motivated the dissent in that the
overturn that ruling was motivated in in
part by some religious views does that
mean that we should still forcibly
sterilized the mentally unfit I don't
think so how about Plessy of you
Ferguson separate but equal how about
all all of the abolition movements in
history and the movements for liberty
have been in in large part motivated by
Christian feeling does that mean we
should get rid of them I don't think so
I don't think so at all it's it's so
it's a bias I think of coastal
Republican types the ones who want to be
cool the socially liberal but fiscally
conservative you know that's like that's
the only way that you can get along go
along to get along now but it's crazy
because politics is downstream of
culture and to go on television and try
to spout this stuff is so I don't blame
her for being ignorant a lot of people
are ignorant what I blame her for is not
having the curiosity to even look into
this to crack the spine of a book
the humility to maybe not shout this
ignorant on national television that's
the trouble here
I wasn't always pro-life I wasn't I
didn't always realize how awful
abortionist in fact I remember vividly
had a conversation while I was in
college I was doing a summer fellowship
with some bioethicists and I had a
conversation with a female bioethicists
at lunch I said well I think abortion I
don't think it's that big a deal people
are so worried about it I don't know and
she she said well why is that Michael I
I repeated all of the Freakonomics
argument so you know which are largely
bogus anyway it lowers crime and it's
this and it's they're not morally
significant blah blah blah and she said
okay so which which of those arguments
doesn't also apply to kill ethnic
minorities in the inner cities young
young male ethnic minorities because
they commit a crime you know it's a law
they were disproportionately on welfare
shouldn't we just kill them and I
thought oh yeah okay and I'd like
cracked the spine of a book I thought
about this for more than five seconds
and I realized the moral gravity of it
she hasn't done that and so if it's fine
she doesn't have to I'm not gonna make
Tommy Lauren read but if she's other
than my but I recommend she does read my
book is that that is a good starter you
know on the path of political philosophy
but but if she's not going to do that
she she really should stop spouting this
ignorance nobody's trying to shut her up
we're trying to educate her and and stop
the spread of such nonsense really
frustrating but I only I only attack
because I love because I want I want the
people who go on Fox News to be better
and stop spouting such nonsense i attack
CNN because I don't love this great clip
you got to say do we have time before we
go we have maybe a little bit of time
before we go you've got to see this clip
a pal of mine who has to remain
anonymous because this career will get
ruined he was watching this live on CNN
and they were translating CNN was
talking to the relatives of you know
illegal aliens who came over and the
kids were detained or whatever and they
were asking what how are the kids doing
what's going on with the kids and here
is what CNN played
he says he wants me to be with him she
says and prays to God to make the day
shorter so we can be together and I
don't know how many of you speak Spanish
out there my Spanish isn't great
I mostly have Italian a little touch of
French but I think what I heard is the
woman said de se que esta muy bien
which roughly translates to yeah he says
he's doing very well but what did see me
play that clip again what did CNN say
she said come again it's like in this
you know in those movies like with the
bad dubbings it'll be a Japanese movie
you know and they'll say like you see
the mouth moving like and then they'll
dump it over and I'll just say like yes
you know he said wait does it sound like
you said more than that did he you know
this is the opposite ear that disa
kissed um we bien he says that he's
doing terribly and Trump's a criminal
and hashtag resists and Brett Kavanaugh
was a Catholic and so he shouldn't be on
the court what all right are you sure
about that unbelievable stuff and
somehow no nobody caught this I think
it's cuz nobody watches CNN so yeah it's
like one conservative every everyday
like one conservative in the country has
to sell flagellate and watch CNN to pull
all the stupid clips so I guess today
that's me
now maybe other people play it too it's
really egregious but that is how
dishonest these people are I mean that
is how that when you turn on CNN which
only exists because of airports because
they made a deal with the devil and with
airports sometime in the 1990s so CNN is
played there all the time if they're not
reporting news they are a fiction
company making a narrative there is
somebody who was writing the script to
this and there was like the background
it's a DC case time we BN it's like okay
well what
there's no way to translate that
cockamamie language how are we how are
we ever gonna find that it's like okay
well I think it sounds a little bit like
Donald Trump is a monster and I hate him
and you should and Hillary should have
been elected hashtag me too so just
wanted to call that dear attention any
time you're tempted to think that we
should watch or listen to CNN
don't do it I've got a second bite of
Facebook in YouTube we've got a great
this day in history coming up today and
it really ties back into our theme of
federalism for only $9.99 per month you
can get a subscription to the daily wire
you got to go over from Facebook and
YouTube you'll get me you get the under
Clavin sure you get the Ben Shapiro show
you ask questions in the mailbag that's
coming up get your mailbag questions in
for tomorrow because it is coming up I'm
gonna start answering those questions
right after this show today and you'll
be able to ask questions in conversation
none of that matters mmm mmm decoe que
esta muy bien de coca ston muy bien
these leftist tears mm-hmm-hmm no no I'm
certain that grammar was completely
wrong but the leftist Jews are really
good these days that really Pope ish
papist papist variety you just smelly
they catch a whiff of that potpourri and
they just start pouring out all their
tears go to daily we're calm we'll be
right back with this day in history
we're back to federalism we're back
because on this day in history in 1804
the Federalist Alexandre Hamilton was
killed in a duel by Aaron Burr what do
we take from this this is such an
American story by the way Alexander
Hamilton is so good even though you know
I I know when people think of Alexander
Hamilton now they think of like a
millennial hip-hop star because that's
just that's the cultural representation
now but he was unbelievable he was so so
good he was born on a Caribbean island
of Nevis in either 18 1755 or 1757 we
don't know because he was this orphan
kid from this Caribbean island he makes
it to the mainland of America in 1773 he
joins the Continental Army almost
immediately and he rises up quickly I
mean this is a kid you know an orphan
from a Caribbean island and he and he
rises up he becomes aid to camp to
President Washington Jenner then General
Washington so he's with them at Valley
Forge he's he's all over then after the
Revolutionary War he becomes a delegate
to the Constitutional Convention and
crafts our Constitution he writes the
Federalist Papers he crafts our idea of
what the country should be and at all
times all these like whenever kind of
crazy Radical factions come up he swoops
in and just makes it all better
he then is appointed first secretary of
the Treasury by President Washington and
he crafts a monetary system for us that
basically prevented us prevented the
government from collapsing early on
prevented the economy and the government
from collapsing really brilliant in his
spare time he founded the Federalist
Party he founded the Coast Guard and he
founded the New York Post talked about a
wide variety of one of the best tabloids
in America founded by the great
Federalists Alexander Hamilton he also
this poor kid from the Caribbean was
educated at King's College which is what
now would be at Columbia University in
Aaron Burr it's really hard to deny the
existence of God and Providence in
history because you get these bizarre
coincidence these bizarre parallel
stories Aaron Burr born around the same
time 1756 so either a year after a year
before Alexander Hamilton he he has like
the opposite light
story he's born into wealth he's born
into privilege he's you know he just
grows up as a rich kid in New Jersey he
attends what is now Princeton then
called the College of New Jersey and he
too joins the Continental Army kid comes
from nothing goes to Columbia kid comes
from everything goes to Princeton they
joined the Continental Army after that
though he didn't distinguish himself in
the way that Alexander Hamilton did so
he goes back to New York not New Jersey
but New York and because is elected to
the New York State Assembly and this is
how I know that Aaron Burr is a is a
monster and a sociopath because with few
exceptions people that go to the New
York State Assembly are just totally
corrupt there are a few exceptions I've
actually have a pal who's in the New
York State Assembly he's one of the most
honorable people I've ever met in
politics
Kevin Bern everyone else up there it's
just a devil you know I think by the
time of the indictments finally end in
the New York State Assembly the New York
State Senate Kevin is gonna be the only
one left up there see the only one with
any dignity it's really of right now
you've got one of the heads of the New
York State Assembly is like throwing his
son under the bus and an indictment and
an investigation just the most corrupt
place in the country so that's where
Aaron Burr goes he's then elected state
attorney and and then their lives
intersect when Aaron Burr beats
Hamilton's father-in-law for a US Senate
seat so now you've got Aaron Burr in the
US Senate
you've got Alexander Hamilton leading
the Federalists crafting our
Constitution and in Secretary of
Treasury
Hamilton early on he had a good gut and
he realized that Burr was a monster he
hated him with a fiery passion he viewed
Burr is a dangerous opportunist and he
said quote I feel it is a religious duty
to oppose his career which really brings
us back to religion too but he just saw
this early on Alexander Hamilton was a
busy guy he was doing a lot of things
starting our monetary system founding
parties writing the Constitution winning
the Revolutionary War he was a very busy
guy he took time out of his very busy
schedule to try to destroy Aaron burrs
career why did he do that
so Adams wins the presidency and after
George Washington and at this point
Aaron Burr who had run for vice
president he was a running mate of
Thomas Jefferson with the
anti-federalists he
left the Senate and returned to the New
York Assembly leaves the federal the US
Senate goes back to the New York State
Assembly isn't that good then Burr to
destroy Hamilton leaks documents of
Hamilton criticizing fellow Federalist
John Adams this may have played a role
in John Adams losing re-election in the
Federalists losing and Thomas Jefferson
coming to power just a you know talk
about the deep state this is Aaron Burr
the first deep state leak this damaging
document on Alexander Hamilton helps him
win helps Jefferson win the 1800 race so
in those days it's not the the president
and vice president were elected were not
elected as they are today the guy who
got the most electoral votes would be
President the second most to be vice
president Jefferson and burr each
received 73 electoral votes so they
should have decided this pretty
technically easily it goes to the House
of Representatives but the Federalists
you know in a move to try to screw
everything up and get back at Jefferson
through their support behind Aaron Burr
so you ended up in the situation where
the that running made the VP nominee
could have become the president over
Thomas Jefferson at this point in
Hamilton has no great love for the
anti-federalists led by Jefferson
Alexander Hamilton gets a bunch of
Federalists to throw their support
behind Jefferson and break the deadlock
and prevent Aaron Burr from being
president why because he viewed Aaron
Burr is a dangerous demagogue so at this
point Aaron Burr has a falling-out with
Jefferson they don't get along that well
and so he goes back to New York again
and seeks the Federalist nomination for
the governor of New York he wasn't anti
federalists now he's a federalist and an
how many of the last governors of New
York haven't just gone to prison I don't
know is there like a you've got all
these awful governors you had Spitzer
you know the sex pervert criminal
Spitzer you had Cuomo definitely has a
ton of skeletons in his closet
you've got Patterson wasn't great so all
of these guys he goes there he once he
wants that job to really fits his
character he loses the race for governor
he loses the nomination race he loses
the independent race for governor at
this point he's extremely angry and he
and Hamilton duel they do will be as
Hamilton has destroyed his entire life's
career now they at these do
very often you'd fire into the air you'd
resolve it peacefully Hamilton was a
fiery guy he'd been in multiple duels in
his life nobody ever died it was very
Court of decided among gentlemen Aaron
Burr was having none of it
he aims right in the center of Alexander
Hamilton's body blows him away shoots
him through the stomach hits his spinal
cord kills Alexander Hamilton there was
a public outcry at this point because
duels were common but killing a man like
Alexander Hamilton is a big deal
so what is Aaron Burr do the little
coward he goes back and stays and as
vice president he's immune from
prosecution
he then flees because he doesn't want to
be prosecuted goes go west young man and
plots with James Wilkinson who is the
commander in chief of the army to try to
take over a part of the continent take
over part of the country and start their
own empire because Aaron Burr apparently
proved Alexander Hamilton right at this
point then they try to get help from the
British that's despicable they then
tried to take over part of Spanish
America when it didn't work out to take
over other parts of America and then
Burr leads an army charging into New
Orleans into the Louisiana territory and
he's put down and he flees to Europe now
why do I bring all of this up well one
it's an interesting story from a merit
early American history but the real
takeaway that you have to remember is
always listen to the Federalists listen
to the Federalist Society listen to the
Federalists of the founding of the
country they have got it right read the
Federalist we were talking about how
it's important for people who are
conservative to read books they should
read the Federalist the Federalists are
always right and people who oppose the
Federalists are murderous traitors I
guess that's is that the take away let's
let's make that to take away get your
mailbag questions in we will take on all
of them tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael moles this
is the Michael Nolt show I'll see you
then
[Music]
the michael noland is produced by seniya
Villarreal executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena
hair and makeup is by Jeshua Elvira the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you
you